hi welcome to a new project camp update
in this video you will see that we cut
down a big bush to plant a new garden
we started to search for a few locations
for making platforms for a yoga deck
and we also went to a tree nursery to
search for some trees some bushes some
flowers to put down in the new garden
so i hope you enjoyed this video
[Music]
i think this is good with the brush
cutter okay so we are going to cut this
bush that looks quite cool because it's
on flowers in
in the spring but during the whole year
it's not that cool
and we want to clear this area so we can
open up a bit more base camp
maybe we have a garden maybe we have a
cinema place maybe we have just square
of the town where we can meet
we don't know yet but we it will open a
big
space on in the kitchen so
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's really eating
up here
well it's just an eater
it's really cute we have a lot of snails
oh yeah
that's interesting before he gets
stepped on
up
[Music]
so
now we're going up
the mountain here
wait
up the mountain there
because there's a really beautiful place
with some nice rocks
and a good view of the valley
and it would be really nice to
use this place as well the bottom is a
bit hard and it cannot be
grown or there's no wood growing with
this just a place of a nice view this
could use some joja decks so people can
also take a bit of relaxed time when
they are a bit done with the business of
the camp
slowly yeah
[Music]
yeah right
yeah but this is definitely definitely a
cool cool possibility we did not even
walk here maybe
kind of nice just a swinging chair could
also be enough here yeah
a giant swing
that sounds nice
[Music]
all right
hey mick yeah
i think this could be a really nice
place because you look
at the other surrounding rocks of the
land
and there's a nice
ancient looking rock here in front
yeah it's surrounded by some nice trees
and a few of the mountains there
yeah
i'm really around this area where you
can really have a panoramic view yeah
and you think
you were thinking so smaller platforms
three by three this was an initial
thought also to give a bit of
if different people want to what have
their space they don't all need to be
together yeah
good view to the east yeah
sunrise
yeah
yesterday it was really beautiful there
was all fog in the
valley and you saw the mountains there
sticking out
the idea is now to do several places so
when people want to be a bit alone
and do their own thing then there also
is place for several people doing this
at the same time
without interfering each other
yeah because this makes really a logical
part yep so actually if people also want
to walk so then you would put it a bit
more in front so you can walk more
easily
you can just
[Music]
we found a really nice old madronja
it's a native tree for this area and the
wood seems to be really good for making
nice stuff with like olive wood or
high quality wood so
let's see what's in there
oh this
i don't want to kill you
[Music]
oh yeah it
this tree is bur it's more bush the bush
is burned so we're not sure if the
wood's still good but
let's have a look
it's a bit dry
i think it still looks good it's a bit
burnt on the outside and the inside is
really dry but
maybe if you take a bigger stem it can
be still
can still be used for something
it's nice it's
really small rings
which means it's a slow growing tree
it's also pretty hard
but here i also really like the eclipse
you do yeah
yeah from here from this point yeah i
think it's very beautiful
don't relate to them emotionally
with uh
yeah yeah yeah with this management that
like yeah just the way they have been
over planted yeah yeah
the madronia can use some more light to
grow a bit bigger
why do people plant as like so many
eucalyptus trees like especially when
they are burned like hell
yeah i mean it's paper industry
that's really they all sell to the paper
industry paper industry portugal
cleaning the ass of europe
what do you mean like the all the paper
the paperwood comes from
toilet paper
so we're using all that eucalyptus trees
here for toilet paper
[Music]
cellulose actually yeah yeah
fast growing trees
uh
easy i mean a lot of
government support for that
so it's really yeah easy money easy
money yeah in principle that's already a
shitty principle like of monocultures of
eucalyptus but the big problem is that
people plant them and like here around
for example most of the lands are like
abandoned
so the eucalyptus obviously grow like
too much close together
so in terms of fire prevention which is
already very poor with the monoculture
when it's an abandoned field of
monoculture then it's just it's
like a lightning match or something yeah
doomed to to feel yeah
how it curves and like the branches like
here
shall we go to a third place yeah let's
do it
so we were thinking we went to this
place
a third option for a deck or another
option for a deck and then we were
really discussing ah wait wouldn't it be
great if we go down
and
find this very different kind of
environment to put it maybe more closer
to the water
and then we got really excited so we're
gonna go down and see if we can find a
nice
place there
[Music]
it may be easy to give them all the same
shape yep
so it's just like yeah
so we just finished the tour around the
places to find the yoga decks and now
this piece will become a garden soon and
for that we need to go to the tree
nursery and get some bushes some trees
and make it beautiful again
[Music]
people are always [ __ ] on this car
because it's the old lady
and it's kind of special first gear is
difficult second gear is difficult you
can't really see the velocity you're
going but it goes up the mountain
like now for example i'm doing the third
now i don't know i don't know it seems
quite complex now to change the gearbox
yeah i think so
but there is this super cool guys
nearby and they will fix
a few parts of the gears
temple
foreign
this is a full
neighbor
name tour
a bit
lacking in confidence
so we just arrived to the tree shop
this is the sign that we just arrived to
the shop and we will get some trees some
bushes some flowers just to expand the
garden
some of the plants last year didn't
survive to winter like teas like
lemongrass tea and i hope i can find it
here so we can put it back into the soil
again
so we are back from the shop we got some
very nice bushes and
one single tree
this is for me a tree that i would not
know how to say the name in english but
it symbolizes spring because it's the
first
fruit of spring which is in portuguese
called neshpara
a yellow fruit like this sized
we have some aromatics and we have a lot
of good smelling flowers and plants and
bushes
it's really not enough for the whole
garden that we want to plant but
parallel to this we also have some
seedlings that are still growing
and we will see what else will be to
complement the garden
we are taking out some bushes and
sometimes it might
seem that they are invasive species or
creating a lot of damage but actually
what they do is that they are nourishing
a lot the soil and this soil is like
super fluffy super nutritious so these
plants will actually have a very good
start for them
what are you eating there
communities
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay
this was the
lemongrass that died last year
so let's see if this survives this
winter
because it was too cold yes
too cold
[Music]
one
two
three
five
six
[Music]
name
yeah that was it for this video we now
reached 100 000 subscribers thank you
guys for supporting we actually reached
this one week ago but you see this one
week later because our patrons if you
support there you can see the video one
week ahead and then you would have this
news on time
anyway thanks for watching see you the
next time